River babes remember at your junior prom
when a crazed murderer chased you around
the school wearing a hook for a hand yet
neither do i but that's what happened to
Betty so let's talk about it
[Music]
hey there river babes
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and this is
your Sweetwater Secrets after-show for
episode 322 chapter 55 prom night you
don't want to sit down for this today
I'll be bringing you an exclusive
interview with KJ APPA spilling a new of
our chi updates plus i've got a
particularly vicious round of hisses and
kisses but first let's recap all the
biggest moments of the night with the
blue and gold breakdown the episode
began with Betty and Veronica driving
out to see the horrific wreck that
supposedly caused her father's death but
despite the evidence Betty was not
believing it what if he planned this
what does he escaped she later received
a phone call from creepy curdle the
coroner who confirmed that the DNA of
one of the hands was housed but she was
determined to brush that craziness aside
and team up with her Bay to investigate
deeper into the gargoyle king and Edgar
ever never I need to keep moving
after Jughead found the gargoyle gospel
he and Betty decided to change the prom
theme to a full-on gng quest in hopes
that it would lure the king out of
hiding it worked but there was also an
unexpected visitor who showed up in the
halls of Riverdale high
that's right the black hood is back but
now he's acting like an effed up mashup
of Peter Pan and I know what you did
last summer cuz he's got a hook for a
hand
after tormenting an attacking Betty all
around the school she hid in the
janitor's closet oh and by the way she
found three dead bodies along the way
because sure
Jughead eventually found her and saved
her but when Betty went to the farm to
tell her mom the truth she did the
unthinkable she agreed to stand under
the farms protection are you out of your
mind over with Archie though writers
have now decided that fred is out of
town so the lovely Molly Ringwald has
graciously returned to reprise her role
as Mary Andrews I just wanted to spend
some time with my son
that's all Mary may not always be around
but she went into full-on mama bear mode
when she heard that Archie wants to skip
college and become a pro boxer I want to
see how far these fists can take me by
the way Veronica is now not only
Archie's ex she's also his boxing
manager and wants to invest as co-owner
of the El Royale gym I wouldn't mind
diversifying my portfolio so here's what
happened Archie forged his mom's
signature so he could fight in a match
the exact same day that he was supposed
to have an exhibition fight with fangs
to impress the Naval Academy recruiter
that Mary brought in to see Archie he
lost the first fight and well he didn't
quite make it to the second
at prom as friends Veronica told Archie
that she discovered that her dad gave
her a fake deed to Pop's and that this
whole time she thought she owned the
diner and la bonne nuit
she was unknowingly still working for
her father and now she's ready to take
him down says you know didn't you know
no I don't know that we know they know
we know and now let's focus on the brief
romantic moments we had in 3:20 with
seven seconds in heaven you know I was
really hoping that we were gonna see two
gorgeous and amazing women be crowned
prom queens at Riverdale high and you
know what Cheryl wanted that too no
other options make sense unfortunately
it seems that being lesbian trailblazers
is not part of the farms bylaws because
both Evelyn and Edgar quickly tried to
squash Cheryl's dreams of wearing
matching crowns with her BAE easy for
you to say Evelyn luckily it seems like
Cheryl is starting to wake up from this
nightmare and suddenly being afar me is
making it a lot less sense to me as for
our other couples well we did get a few
brief scenes with bug-head being all
kinds of adorable will you go to prom
with me only for you Betty Cooper and
even though it was a blinkin you'll miss
it moment Kevin and fangs were there but
the most non shocking surprise was the
fact that Veronica Archie decided to go
to prom together as friends we're just
going as friends
we're just friends yeah uh-huh friends
are you sure about this now take a look
at what KJ up I had to tell me when I
asked him about these rekindled barchi
vibes I liked it I mean it's always
promising to me to see Veronica and achi
getting back together and I think the
Vashi fans will be frothing for that
it's a good episode for sure it's not as
good as the last episode people are
going to be losing their minds when they
see the last one and now let's switch
over to hisses and kisses kicking this
off with massive hisses to Edgar for
blackmailing Cheryl for running for prom
queen rude I'm afraid we can't have you
speaking with your brother Jason any
longer
hisses to the fact that Kevin is once
again just a glorified extra he deserves
more thank you Andrew those random
Southside serpents that we saw in the
classroom has anyone seen sweet pea
hi I'm Sweet Pea kisses to all the dead
bodies in this
so at this point death doesn't even mean
anything anymore in Riverdale it happens
all the time
and half of them seem to come back to
life anyways I'm just really tired of it
whatever and lastly hisses to Betty and
Jughead whoa wait hear me out first
hisses to the fact that when they were
questioning the tattoo artist about
those symbols they truly didn't listen
to his description what did he look like
sandy hair blue eyes weirdly magnetic
that's the guy they were so determined
to believe that it was Edgar who looks
amazing shirtless by the way does that
satisfy you that they didn't even think
about another blonde psychopath chick
you guys I'm calling it now chick is the
gargoyle king after Hal chased him
through the woods he didn't kill him
instead he told him all about the time
that he was the gargoyle king in high
school and he convinced his kind of fake
son to continue his serial killer spree
for him
I would honestly love that kisses to me
for that awesome theory humility and now
let's switch over to some non conceited
kisses kisses to the brother-sister
bonding between Jughead and jelly bean
to the fact that apparently FP can't
solve any crime without jugheads help
and to jugheads chip addiction this
season I do not know why but it brings
me a lot of joy kisses to the Riverdale
writers for calling out the fact that
over just three seasons Riverdale has
completely transformed from an eerie
highschool drama to a wildly bizarre and
totally unbelievable murder mystery
promised this weekend we still do things
like that here oh and kisses to Betty
why oh I don't know maybe because her
mom is a brainwashed robot and her
father is a deranged hook for a hand
maniac who faked his own death and
chased his daughter around school while
her fake half-brother stood and watched
while holding some twigs and she did all
of this while wearing heels hey if you
need a couple days
you can take a break and kisses to Mary
Andrews for being the voice of reason on
the fact that Archie has been getting
the crap kicked out of him all season
long I won't support you getting
pummeled and kisses to Molly Ringwald
for coming back to Riverdale when
emotions read an all-time high following
Luke Perry's passing with Fred now out
of town take a look at what KJ Appa had
to say about how the Riverdale writers
will be handling Fred's absence moving
forward I think more importantly his
legacy is gonna live on in the lives
around him that he worked with you know
I'm never gonna forget him yeah it's
still still very fresh and I think we're
all still kind of dealing with it
Fred is now out of town will we see
Molly stick around how Oh Fred's absence
continued to be addressed we're
definitely going to you know obviously
have to address it at some point whether
that's Molly stepping in as more of an
active parent bachi again that depends
on the availability of the actors around
us you know we'll do what we can and now
we're done thank you so much for tuning
in to the Sweetwater after-show and now
we only have two more episodes left in
Riverdale's third season which means
only for more episodes of Sweetwater
let's end this nightmare check back with
me next week for another live Sweetwater
preview of episode 321 chapter 56 the
dark secret of harvest house but for now
please give this video a like and hit
that subscribe button and Men dance your
way on down to the comments to tell me
your hisses and kisses of prom nights
what did you think of the return of the
black hood how long is this hole barchi
just being friends thing really going to
last and who else
totally thinks that I'm right about
chick being The Gargoyle King and
following in house psychotic footsteps
tell me and I'll see you soon river
babes bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]